i hate intros i'm standing on a million
lives season one episode one quick kick
things off with the main character
yusuke yotsiya who's kind of a quiet kid
in class
one day after class he notices two girls
paying an odd amount of attention to him
the first character is the sexy blonde
in
and the girl with her is the timid
fragile kusey hakuzaki
once his teacher is done talking to him
he is then transported to another world
and nearly killed by a sea creature
when he gets to safety he sees the two
girls from his class waiting for him
they don't really get a chance to say
anything because they come face to face
with the
game master the game master then goes on
to explain the rules and what's expected
of them
they have 14 days to work together and
fulfill the village
chief's request this is one of 10 quests
that they're going to be confronted with
once each quest in the ten quest series
is completed they get another member
from the real world to help them with
the following quests
he also learns that shindo is a level
three wizard with the wind attribute and
hakuzaki is a level one warrior the
gamemaster then spins a wheel to find
yotsuya's new class
my boy gets a tiny bit [ __ ] because he
lands on the unlikely former class
with his class decided the game master
then leaves to let them get started on
their quest
the two then feel yotiya on what exactly
is going on
shendo was the first to be brought into
this world and had to complete a quest
by herself
once she had completed that quest she
went back to the real world where the
game master
tasked her with another quest of
befriending kakuzaki
the next time shindo was brought into
this world hakuzaki was also transported
with her
after the two had completed their second
quest they returned to the real world
and were ordered to be alone with
yotsuya
they also explained that by squinting he
can bring up a hud that contains all of
his weapons
the problem is he can only wield weapons
in his class so all he has
is a hoe and a sickle to work with
he realizes that pain and sensations are
a fraction of what they experience in
the real world
while walking they come across a log
point the log points store
scenes from events that have already
happened and you can access them by
touching it when yatsuya touches it he
sees hakuzaki having a breakdown in
front of shindo because she wasn't
exactly
mentally prepared to get transported to
another world everyone comes across a
group of goblins cueing yosuya's first
fight in the new world this winds up not
going so well because his weapon breaks
and we find out that the other two are
[ __ ] useless
shindo the mighty wind wizard is a
glorified fan and hakuzaki
is just a [ __ ] after hakuzaki throws
her sword we see that yotsuya tries to
pick it up but he can't
instead he tries switching to his hoe it
immediately breaks and then he gets hit
and killed he has an out of body
experience but then comes back to life
soon after
when somebody dies they respawn after 30
seconds has passed this seems pretty op
but if all of them die at the same time
then they actually die in real life also
with that in mind shindo hangs back to
stay safe while yotsuya continuously
throws himself at the goblins chipping
away at them and ultimately killing all
of them
later that night we find out they have a
map of the areas they've explored and
also that yotsuya's weapons are going to
take
5 days to regenerate he also learns that
every time they complete a quest the
reward for completing the quest is that
they get to ask the game master one
question
when shindo completed her quest by
herself she asked why she was chosen the
game master simply responded
that somebody you know requested it
after they had completed the second
quest hakuzaki asked who are you people
he then just responds that they are from
the future while yotsuya is outslaying
goblins to level up a bit he then hears
a commotion and when he returns to camp
he finds that hakuzaki is badly injured
he sees a massive creature nearby who
had grabbed shindo and eats her alive
knowing that they can't defeat it as
they are now he grabs hakuzaki and makes
a run for it when hakuzaki wakes up she
realizes that her hand isn't
regenerating most likely because it was
eaten they figured the same thing with
shindos so since she was eaten it's
likely she won't respawn
they arrive at a town where we learned
that all of the locals in this world
recognize people from the other world
and call them heroes
they had gone there to talk to the
village chief and find out what he wants
so that they can complete the quest and
go back to their world
the problem with that is the chief is
asking them to defeat the troll that had
killed shindo
episode 2. you'd see it goes out by
himself to fight some monster so he can
rank up in order to fight the troll
he keeps on fighting goblins until he's
on the brink of level 10.
then out of nowhere he realizes that
kazooie was slain
when he gets back to the village she
realizes it's under attack and that's
why she was killed
she isn't reviving so he can assume that
she was eaten by the troll also
he finds a log point of kazooie talking
with a little kid she explains that in
real life she has a condition that
prevents her from doing any strenuous
activity
because of this she's not exactly used
to doing so many physical things which
is why she's so [ __ ] useless despite
that she still feels bad about being a
burden on everybody and is trying to get
better about it we also see that she was
eaten by the troll because she was
trying to protect some of the villagers
when he starts fighting the troll he
realizes that he can only jump
forward like a frog if he changes
directions at the last second then the
troll can't get to him he gets put in a
bad spot and the troll is about to get
him but then he sees a goblin so he
rushes him to get his level 10. when he
stabs the goblin he gets level 10
and the world freezes because he's level
10 the game master then shows up and
spins to the job roulette again
this time he lands on the chef class the
chef class is just added to his kit so
it doesn't actually replace the farmer
kit the chef ability allows him to get a
blade as well as seize the internal
organs of the troll
when time resumes he uses both his knife
and his new knowledge to stab the troll
in the stomach
because his stomach was cut open shindo
and kisue were both set free and respawn
even though they're all back they still
don't have an attack strong enough to
penetrate the troll's muscles
they change up their strat and yotsuya
jumps into the troll's stomach and stabs
him from within
this creates an opening for shindo to
jump on his back and launch a burst of
air into the troll's head and pops him
like a balloon now that the troll is
defeated the game master shows up and
yotsuya gets to ask his question
he decides to ask the gamemaster after
the 10th quest is completed what happens
to them
he shows them the future where tokyo is
under attack the three of them are there
defending the city when
a massive monster comes down from the
sky after getting a good look at the
creature they then appear back in their
world
no time had passed while they were in
the other world so now they have to go
about their daily routines as usual
in the last couple of scenes we see that
yusuke is in a bit of a dilemma
he's trying to decide if tokyo the city
that he hates so much is actually worth
saving
episode 3. well for a run yusuke gets a
call from the game master the game
master tasks him with going to find a
girl and hitting on her well following
the game master's instructions he has
led to a group of girls stripping and
taking pictures of another girl game
master tells him that the girl being
bullied is the one he has to hit on
fearing that the girl might commit
suicide if the other girls post her
pictures on the internet he decides to
break all of the other girls phones
the three girls run off so yosuke
escorts the victim back home this is
when he meets and learns a little bit
more about yuka tokitate
the girls had targeted yuuka because she
was talking [ __ ] about one of them so
she wanted to get her back
two weeks after the incident the
original trio plus yuka are transported
to the other world once again
when yuka rules for her job she gets a
wizard of heat
they also learned that as they get more
members things will get harder so their
respawn timer went from 30 seconds
up to 40 seconds their next quest
consists of two steps the first step is
traverse five percent of the map and the
second step is deliver the goods to
radodorvo he doesn't specify what the
goods are but they have 40 days to
complete this
while walking through a field a huge
insect crashes into the ground nearby
them it spawns some sort of centipede
thing that launches bugs at them and
starts one-tapping them
we learned that yuuka is a low level so
she's just as useless as the other two
yusuke is pretty much forced to do
everything while the girls stand nearby
and just watch him he jumps on the bug's
back and cuts off its legs one at a time
until it can't fight anymore once that's
done kazooie is gonna have to deal the
killing blow with her sword she's still
[ __ ] useless so yusuke has to hold
her hand to guide her
on how to kill it we then get a
flashback of shindo when she was a
little girl and she was apparently a
problematic child
she kept getting into fights with other
kids until she meets an older girl named
sayori who encourages her not to
say yuri had something wrong with her
face and this ultimately led to her
killing herself
this was a pretty defining moment in her
life and in the last couple of scenes we
see that she's still having nightmares
about it today
episode 4 sayuri was apparently being
bullied in school which was what led to
her suicide
shendo wound up being bullied also but
not by other kids it was actually the
adults in her life who targeted her
because her father was a biker thug who
made their lives difficult when
everybody returns to the village that
they had saved earlier they find it in
ruins and with nobody around
they come across a man who says that
he's been stopping by this village for
the past five years and it's always been
deserted
this means that time moves faster in
this world as opposed to the real world
the man then gives them directions on
how to get to ratadorvo the only problem
with that is that it's on the other side
of the continent he says that it would
take them roughly 30 days to travel that
distance on horseback with only 40 days
to complete the quest their only option
is to find some horses before they start
going there
the man suggests attending a nearby
martial arts tournament the prize for
winning the tournament is
three horses while heading to the city
where the tournament is being held they
are then ambushed by a group of bandits
they go to fight with the bandits but
when yusuke stabs one of them he can
hear the gamemaster's voice
the game master explains that it's
prohibited to deal damage to any humans
as punishment yusuke loses experience
points and his chef skill gets demoted
they try making a run for it but shindo
ends up getting captured by them the
group contemplates whether they should
go on without shindo because technically
they don't need her to complete the
quest they decide the best course of
action is to have yusuke go and attend
the tournament while kasue and yuka go
to rescue shindo their rescue operation
goes extremely well as they get captured
also yusuke realizes that they've been
captured on the map so he goes around
killing goblins until he gets another
job roulette this time he doesn't get
really [ __ ] on this thing so he
becomes a creature wizard the creature
skills are [ __ ] irrelevant so he
attends the tournament and gets killed
in the first round after the fight he
talks with the woman who had
defeated him named cahavelle she winds
up winning the entire tournament and the
horses
yusuke offers to give for the location
of the bandits camp where the others are
being held in exchange for the horses
they take it to kahabel's leader who
agrees to this after the deal is made
kahubel
also offers to train him in sword
fighting he learns a little bit more
about fighting and then kahabel along
with her men launched the attack on the
bandit camp
during the fight yusuke realizes that as
long as he's just countering and not
attacking directly then he won't lose
any
experience points getting desperate the
bandits decide to unleash their secret
weapon
in a berserker this forces connor bell
to bust out her secret weapon in roika
yexa
she gets her precious sword knocked away
so yosuke has to jump to her defense and
block the next attack
one of the perks of being a creature
wizard is that he has increased
persuasiveness so he tells the berserker
there's someone behind him he turns
around and this creates an opening for
kahabel to go in and finish him with one
blow
he manages to get to the others and
explain everything that had happened
kaha bell chimes in and offers to take
some time off along with some of her men
to be their escort
and in return for this she wants two
things the first thing being that when
they arrive they have to return her
horse
and the second condition is that she
gets to train all four of them and how
to fight with swords
episode five we get a quick flashback of
kazooie growing up
she was always failing pe because of her
condition this is what made her want to
go into pharmaceuticals so that she
could make a drug that would heal her
and her mom who are both afflicted with
the same condition she also appears to
be struggling with all of the violence
unfolding in this world and watching all
of the bandits get killed turns out the
reason conable wants to train the heroes
is because she has some sort of weird
fetish where she likes cutting flesh
because they're heroes she can cut away
at them all she wants and they'll just
regenerate two of conibelle's
subordinates went out to get supplies
and were ambushed by goblins and injured
we see that yosuke has the ability to
enhance their cellular metabolism so
that they can heal a little bit faster
seeing this makes kasuway reflect on how
useless she is so she goes back to
training harder with gonabel
the convoy then comes across a horde of
goblins connor bell offers to wipe them
out but yusuke insists that they need
the combat training so they'll go fight
instead
everyone's doing pretty well except for
kazooie who had gotten her first kill on
a goblin and is struggling to process it
the event ultimately increases her
resolve though as she gets more mentally
sturdy and the concept of killing
something the next day while traveling
they see an army getting attacked by
monsters
they decide that this could be some sort
of event and game master could be
watching
this makes them decide to split up which
makes no [ __ ] sense so yusuke and
kasuway go to fight the monsters while
everybody else continues on
they both get [ __ ] up the first time
around but when kasuy responds she gets
a new idea
since she isn't strong enough to lift
her long sword she waits till one of the
monsters rushes her and then summons it
at the last second the monster runs into
it and dies and then reinforcements show
up in the form of codabell because
apparently that plan just went out the
window yusuke absorbs magic from the
monster's blood which allows him to heal
all of the injured people
when they talk to one of the soldiers
they find out that these guys are
soldiers from the kingdom of dioc
they're acting on orders from their king
to transport heretics to ratadorbo
once they had arrived they are planning
on executing all of the heretics
it's possible that these heretics are
the goods that they're supposed to
deliver to rata dorbo but once they're
there since they're going to be executed
they're not really sure what they're
supposed to do
episode 6 the heroes discuss what to do
because this could be a test to see if
they're actually willing to sacrifice
innocent people to complete the quest
they decide to escort the prisoners to
ride a doorbell and then once they're
there they're going to try and stop the
execution
they convince the dia commander camille
to let them travel along with them while
traveling a missionary named
fossel decides to fill everybody in on
what's going on the kingdom of dia kills
all
ardara's believers because of this the
deox soldiers are planning to execute
the heretics
this is because the kingdom is divided
between citizens who worship the
king and citizens who worship both the
king and god
things escalate until eventually at
least at the prohibition of the religion
as well as the execution of the
believers
they then go to ask camille's why he's
undergoing this dangerous journey just
to execute some heretics he explains
it's to set an example
red adorbo is the first place the
believers show up at when they're
escaping to this continent he is hoping
that the executions will send them a
clear message right as they arrive
the convoy decides that in order to
avoid some steep slopes they have to
take an underground route
this path turns out to be a trap by the
deox soldiers
since they're now locked inside the
tunnels they have to continue on through
an assortment of puzzles
and booby traps yusuke gets caught in
one of the booby traps and knocked out a
huge ledge to where he can't get back to
the others they figure out how to get
past the booby trap but have to leave
yosuke behind yusuke is able to cut the
walls with his cleaver so he can make
footholes in order to climb out then in
the last couple of scenes the others
come across
a gargoyle who is going to be their last
challenge in the tunnels
episode seven yusuke is making decent
progress but keeps falling to his death
while doing it
gonna belt is then stabbed by the
gargoyle and falls off a ledge
as the gargoyle goes to finish off
shindo she steps on a bat and kills it
giving her level 10.
time freezes and she gets to play the
job roulette
she rolls warrior and since time was
frozen this gives her an opportunity to
think about her attack and creates an
opening on the gargoyle
despite creating the opening she still
can't penetrate the gargoyle's defenses
she then thinks back on kyle bell's
training and how she should aim for the
heart
with that thought in mind she's able to
stab the gargoyle in the heart and
defeats it right as
yusuke is showing up he jumps in the
water and gets the cowbell in order to
save her he then continuously heals her
while restoring his mp with monster's
blood until he eventually passes out my
boy's kind of in there though because
she is moved by this gesture and decides
to kiss him she then talks about the
girls about how her country has a
ranking system for knights
out of the 3 000 people in the rankings
she is ranked 70th within the ranking
system only the top 100 are able to gain
the title of knight her father is ranked
second her older brother is ranked 8th
and her younger brother
is ranked 15th when yusuke wakes up he
comes to a realization
the quests up until this point have been
rather vague the first one was to kill a
goblin but it didn't specify which type
the next one was to find two settlements
but it didn't specify which settlements
to find
he suggests operating under the
assumption that this could mean any
goods
on the other hand if the heretics do
turn out to be the goods they have to
take that into consideration too in the
last couple of scenes they decide the
best thing to do
is of course split up episode 8 when
they split up they're gonna have one
group go after the deox soldiers while
the other group goes to find any cargo
heading towards the city
team a consists of one of kahapel's
underlings kazooie and
shindo that of course leaves cabell yuka
and yusuke and the other one
team a travels along the main road
looking for cargo to help escort
meanwhile team b is tracking where the
deoc wagon had gone so they can find him
the only problem is that before kabul
had left the convoy she had noticed
something the deox soldiers were using
messenger birds presumably communicating
with the kingdom they're from
the message most likely contained
information on them trying to trap
courtnell soldiers
if their message was sent and then their
troops go missing they could assume that
cornell had done something to him
because they are such a confrontational
nation they can then use this to declare
war
dioc has 10 times as many soldiers as
kavel's country so they need to avoid
this at all costs
later that night yosuke and yuuka
approached camille saying they want to
negotiate
they lied to camille saying that yosuke
had converted to the religion of arteros
he then tells him that he's there to
negotiate for his three fellow
believers if camille doesn't hand him
over then he threatens to spread the
teachings all over the world and they
can't stop him because he's immortal
they give camille
and his men the rest of the night to
think it over yuka then comes back later
saying that she wants to sell yusuke out
camille orders one of his men to go with
him and yuka to find where yusuke is
while the other stays behind to watch
the prisoners
after walking for a bit they realize
that yuko was just leading them away so
they take her into custody when they get
back to the camp they find josuke there
waiting for them he claims to have
killed
all of the prisoners they were escorting
to get revenge on them for trapping them
in the cave he took one of the heretics
closed and put it on the guard who was
watching the prisoners
then once camilla had arrived yusuke
burns the guard alive to make it seem
like he had killed the preacher
they then send their cargo running and
escape with the last remaining horse
camille can only explain to the higher
ups that he betrayed a hero and they got
revenge on them this
ensures that no war will break out
between the two countries after their
little act is over yusuke and yuka
return to a cave where the prisoners are
hiding
yuka is very conflicted after killing
the guard who was watching the prisoners
yusuke's logic is that since they're
alive they can't value the characters in
a game more than themselves he had also
lost experience on his wizard ranking
down ranking him to level
episode 9. we see camille and his last
remaining man
sending a messenger bird back to dioc
explaining their failure
as soon as the bird is gone kybell comes
out of nowhere and kills both camille
and his man to get revenge for her
fallen comrade now we hop on over to the
king of dioc who meets with a mysterious
new character
they discuss that they need to find a
way to deal with the heroes and kill
them permanently
while continuing on to ratador bro we
see that kabel is struggling with her
feelings for yusuke
and wants to find an opportunity to
confess to him yuka had picked up on
this so she starts trying to play
matchmaker for yusuke and kabel this
leads to a bunch of filler content that
is completely [ __ ] irrelevant kazooie
and
shindo had finally found a wagon going
to ride adorbo
then i kahabelle finally gets her
opportunity to talk to yusuke but it
turns out all she wanted to say was that
she was grateful to him
for helping a venture comrade the quest
ended when they exposed camille and his
men for their atrocities and delivered
their severed heads to the guards at
rotted orbo
everybody reconvenes after the quest is
completed and now all they have to do is
traverse more of the map
episode 10. to be as efficient as
possible they decide to split up to
traverse more of the map quicker a
blizzard then rolls in out of nowhere
making it difficult for the heroes to
explore the land
yusuke fears that if they die out in
this cold they won't be able to revive
and they'll just be permadeathed to no
one's surprise kuwait is the first one
to collapse and fall unconscious
soon it's only yusuke left trying to
traverse the map because he has the best
equipment to survive in the cold
out of nowhere he comes face to face
with the cyclops yeti and has to fight
it
he manages to kill the yeti but then he
realizes that the reason the yeti was
attacking him is because it had children
that it was trying to feed
without the adult yeti around it's
likely that the babies will starve or
freeze to death but yusuke refuses to
worry about that since they're virtual
in the last couple of scenes yosuke
suddenly falls into a chasm and dies
episode 11 yosuke had fallen into some
caves which raised his body temperature
enough to revive
kasuy has officially died and can't
revive because she's stuck in the storm
meanwhile shindo continues walking
because the winds have calmed down a
little bit and sees a village in the
distance
while she's heading towards it she
realizes that she's walking on ice and
breaks through into the water this kills
her without the chance of being revived
also
while exploring the dungeon yosuke comes
across dead end after dead end when he
has nowhere else to go
an earthworm suddenly appears and
creates a tunnel for him to crawl
through
while crawling through it a predator
sneaks up behind him and eats him
now that he's dead only yooka is left
alive she considers giving up but then
hallucinates characters from an anime
she used to watch that encourage her to
go on
it looks like they're never going to be
able to make it in time until she comes
across a woman named fatina
but dina has a big ass cat so she
decides to give yuka a ride she is able
to complete the quest just in time and
everybody else responds to talk to the
game master
for yuca's question to the game master
she decides to ask if this world is
actually a virtual world game master
explains that it's not a virtual world
but a parallel world to theirs
the only things that are virtual in this
world are actually the players which is
why they can come back to life this
makes yusuke reflect on the fact that he
had actually killed a living person
episode 12. they're all transported back
to the real world but yusuke still isn't
handling this realization too well
everyone realizes that even though they
were in the other world their stamina
has actually gotten better
while walking he gets a message from the
game master asking now that you've
killed somebody what are your honest
feelings
he's still very conflicted so he just
deletes the message without responding
since he didn't respond the game master
shows up at his house disguised as a
little girl
when asked again he just says that he
wished he wouldn't have done it and the
only reason he did is because he thought
they were virtual
now that's settled the game master then
wants him to go and meet their next
player
they go to a chinese restaurant where
the game master points out a man at the
end of the counter who is formerly a
drug dealer she then explains that the
next player is about to come in in 20
seconds and kill the man
yusuke steps in to deter the attack and
fights with all of them he is able to
identify which one the player is
and pulls off his mask coming face to
face with the 19 year old tory
the mandatory is working for realizes
that something is going wrong so he
comes in and pulls a gun on yusuke to
prevent him from dying the game master
gives him a glove
the glove lets him access his creature
wizard abilities in this world so he is
able to order the man to stop from
pulling the trigger
this gives him the opportunity to beat
the [ __ ] out of the man and convince his
tory and his little brother to escape
from the police
usuke comes to the realization that the
game master is preventing bad things
from happening to the players so that
once they're in the other world they
will still want to come back to this
world
if tory and his brother were arrested
then they wouldn't care about getting
back to this world which is what the
game master is trying to prevent this
doesn't change yusuke's thinking on how
he values people's lives
he believes that people who can be
convinced to kill should die so he
doesn't actually care about tory or his
well-being the only value he sees in
tory's life is the ability to complete
the next quest
this is a pretty shitty take and not
exactly the answer the game master was
looking for the game master points out
that he looks at the value of human
lives like an anonymous internet user
yusuke completely agrees and says that
he has delusions of grandeur thinking
that he is right and everybody else is
wrong even though he can identify that
this is delusional thinking he still
chooses to embrace it
but anyways i'm gonna be doing the next
season and you can find that in the left
side whenever i'm finished with it or
you can check out all the i'm standing
on a million lives recaps in the
playlist on the right side you can also
find the links in the description below
and the only thing i hate more than
intros
is outros
you